- Ось тут одна, друга
була отута,
простирадлом накрита,
а третю я
просто ось так тримав, грівся.
Так, обнімаючи не м’яку іграшку,
а пляшку з гарячою водою, засинав 12-річний Женя зі Сміли.
Нині батареї в його кімнаті теплі.
У місті з затримкою на місяць нарешті розпочався опалювальний сезон.
Мама хлопчика Світлана радіє і обурюється одночасно.
- Включать і потім поставлять умови:
ось ми вам включили, а ви далі робіть чи сплачуйте, чи як далі?
Хто візьме за це відповідальність?
Ми не знаємо.
І люди, звісно, всі обурені.
Хвилювання Світлани небезпідставне.
Тепло місту дали лише після того, як містяни
приїхали з протестами під Кабмін
і президент Порошенко втрутився із вказівкою
забезпечити теплопостачання. Головна ж проблема
- конфлікт через борги між "Нафтогазом" та компанією "Смілакомунтеплоенерго" -
досі не вирішена. Світлана боїться, аби борги
не переклали на плечі містян, які вже сплатили за послуги.
- У нас по будинку немає боргів ні за воду, ні за тепло.
У нас стабільно люди намагаються платити,
бо розуміють, що платять за надання послуг.
І хочуть мати ті послуги відповідної якості.
Проблеми з початком опалювального сезону у Смілі
почалися ще два роки тому. Тоді мерія вирішила
розірвати контракт з приватним постачальником тепла
"СмілаЕнергоінвест" на користь комунального "Смілакомунтеплоенерго".
Повноваження передали, а ось борги приватної фірми
перед "Нафтогазом" переймати не захотіли.
85 мільйонів гривень, кажуть чиновники,
- непід'ємна сума для міста. У "Нафтогазі" натомість
посилаються на Закон України "Про теплопостачання", за яким
правонаступником боргів компанії-попередника
є  новий теплопостачальник. Поки вирішували, хто кому заборгував,
у дитячих садках діти спали при температурі 10 градусів.
Школи закрили. А в лікарнях на свій страх і ризик
палати опалювали електрообігрівачами.
- Ось-ось думали, що включать це опалення.
А потім різке похолодання, мережа не витримувала, почались відключення електрики,
Почалися вони часті, почалися вони такі, що навіть
це повністю знеструмлювало лікарню.
І поки ми відновлювали, минав час.
Добре, що  один раз повезло, нікого не оперували в цей час,
ніхто в пологах не знаходився, другий раз теж, а на третій раз може трапитися біда.
Те що сталося у Смілі, наступного року
може повторитися і в інших містах України.
Тільки за два роки борги теплопостачальників перед "Нафтогазом"
зросли уп’ятеро. І надалі ці борги лише збільшуватимуться, вважає
голова Асоціації споживачів енергетики та комунальних послуг Андрій Герус.
За фактом зриву опалювального сезону у Смілі
уже відкрито кримінальне провадження.
Відповідальним чиновникам загрожує
арешт до шести місяців або обмеження волі до трьох років.
- Я підтримую думку депутатів, що
борги енергоінвестора не потрібно брати на місто,
То борги приватної компанії, і треба це
вирішувати у правовому полі.
- Боргів немає, я працюю в бюджеті, боргів нема.
Ні в кого немає. У кого є борги, то хай погасять, і вже менше буде.
Хай спочатку заплатять за газ ті, хто топили.
- Оплачено, хай вже думають вони своєю башкою,
як далі жити людям чесним, роботящим.
У понеділок діти Сміли нарешті пішли до школи.
Життя 70-тисячного міста поволі налагоджується,
як і решти 22 населених пунктів України,
де опалювальний сезон стартував зі значним запізненням.
Мешканці Сміли сподіваються, що вирішиться і конфлікт із "Нафтогазом"
і вони не побачать у своїх платіжках захмарну суму чужих боргів.